TOM KOCHAN: Well, good
afternoon, everyone,
or good morning or good evening.
No matter where you
are in the world,
it's some time of
the day or night.
And I'm delighted that
we can use this time now
to provide a wrap-up
to the journey
that we've been on for
the last seven weeks.
We've covered a lot of ground.
We've looked at a lot
of different issues
that are so central to our
future, to the future of work.
And today, what we want to
do is to try to take stock.
What did we learn?
Where are we going?
How are we going to individually
and then collectively make
this a better workplace for
the future for all concerned?
So I'm really pleased that we
can have this session in a very
interactive way.
And as we indicated on
the course materials,
you can post questions or
comments as we go along.
Some of you, I know,
are already on Twitter.
There's the hashtag,
and I believe
that's going to continue to
show for you, those of you who
are comfortable using Twitter.
And one of our colleagues
here in the classroom
will convey your
questions or comments.
You can also post on
the discussion board
where we put a heading
for the live discussion.
So let's make this really
an interactive session.
I'm joined here this
afternoon by our MBA
class that has been working
with us throughout the semester.
As you know, many of them served
as expert facilitators for you.
So now they all
have a certificate
in mediation and facilitation.
They're experienced,
and they're going
to go out and start doing this
in the workplace of the future.
But we'll take questions and
comments from our colleagues
here because they've been
following and working
on the same issues as we've
been going through this course.
So why don't we get started?
And let's see a little
bit first, who are we?
Well, I want to
thank our partners.
This enterprise is only
possible because we
have a lot of good organizations
that are working together
to make it possible,
starting with edX and MITx,
our platform and
our delivery source,
and the team of people
working behind the scenes
to do the videos with me
and with our colleagues
and to do the editing and to
put the materials on the course
site, all part of this process.
I'm very pleased
that we have partners
at both Cornell University
and the School of Labor
and Industrial Relations
and at Rutgers University
and the School of Management
and Labor Relations,
where classes have taken the
course on their own campus.
And in fact, we're going to draw
on some of the material that
were provided by students
from those classes
as we move along
here this afternoon.
And then, finally,
our colleagues
at the Hitachi Foundation.
You saw one video that
Barbara Dyer helped
to produce on entrepreneurship.
Well, the Hitachi Foundation
is a partner with us
throughout this course in
providing materials and support
as we go along.
So with the MIT
School of Management,
with our Institute for Work
and Employment Research,
we have lots of organizations
supporting this enterprise.
And then, who are we?
Well, we are at 4,299
students and counting.
That number went
up this morning,
so I suspect it may continue
to grow as we go along
and as we keep this material
live on the course site.
But it's a very,
very diverse class,
and that's what makes
it really interesting--
144 countries.
We have people-- a
wide distribution
of educational backgrounds,
from high school, some students
in high school,
students graduated
from high school in technical
and vocational schools,
many who have gotten
four-year degrees,
and a large number
with advanced degrees.
So it's a group that reflects
the notion that education
is important, a theme that we
beat over the head very hard
throughout the course and
we'll continue to talk
about here this afternoon.
Also, a very interesting
age distribution.
The median age is 31.
But if you look at
this distribution,
you see that there are
many younger people
and then a spattering of
people more senior to age 31,
all the way up to
someone in their 90s.
So welcome to our
senior citizens
who are still interested in
shaping the future of work.
I think that's fantastic.
So gender-- we have majority of
males but a good distribution.
We have distribution
also in terms
of backgrounds in industries.
I don't put it on
the slides here,
but we have people
with experience
in all different
industries and occupations.
We have people who
are union members
or have been union
members, about 18% or 19%.
That's a larger number than
you find in the United States
in the distribution
of the population.
But then around
the world it's more
reflective of the
workforce as we find it,
and people of all different
occupational levels,
from entry level to PhDs
and advanced professionals,
people working in
the gig economy,
and people working in
more standard settings.
So we learned a lot
from each other.
And let's take a look at what
some of the overriding lessons
are.
I put three lessons
here that reflect
really the motivation
for this course
and that were
emphasized throughout.
And I'll only use
these to introduce
where we're going to go.
But basically you
put a lot of emphasis
on this "high road/low
road" distinction,
as we did in teaching
this material,
that we know that there are
choices that companies can make
to create good organizations
that are financially
successful, and
that if they follow
a set of well-defined
practices, that can also
be good for their employees.
But not all firms
compete that way.
Not all firms are
organized that way.
And so we emphasized and you
emphasized the importance
of trying to encourage
more "High Road"
firms as a key takeaway
lesson from this course.
We also emphasize something
that many found surprising,
the notion that we need to
rebuild worker bargaining
power, particularly here
in the United States,
but increasingly
across the world.
And some of you reminded
us in the discussion forum
as late as this afternoon that,
in some parts of the world,
workers don't have a
legal right to organize,
or a legal right to
voice their concerns,
or that their efforts
are suppressed
in a variety of ways.
And so we have to respect
workers for their rights,
for the dignity of work, and
the opportunity for expressing
their concerns with power
and with effectiveness
so that they can contribute
both to their own improvements
but also to the viability
of their enterprises.
And then finally, this emphasis
on trying to get business,
and labor, education, and
government working together.
We particularly feel it
here in the United States
at the moment, with the
rhetoric, the unfortunate
rhetoric, and my personal
view that is so active
and maybe even dominating
our political campaign
at the moment, with people not
respecting each other's rights,
each other's backgrounds,
each other's traditions,
and each other's preferences.
And I think we've
got to find ways
to get across these
interest group
lines to solve some
of these problems.
So that's a bit of an
overview of what we've covered
and some of the major themes.
Now let's dig a
little bit deeper.
And let's start with, what
do you want from work?
Remember, we started
with a question right
at the beginning of the class.
What's the most important
priority for you
when you think about what
you're looking for in your work
and in your careers?
And the results are
quite interesting,
and I think they're more nuanced
than even this pie chart shows.
Yes, number one is
getting a good balance
between work and family life.
26% of you rated that
your top priority,
followed very closely by
this interesting concern
for having an
impact, for dealing
with real problems, significant
problems, in your society
and your location,
your community.
You want to address the issues
that are in front of us today.
Maybe it's dealing
with climate change
and saving the
planet for yourselves
and the next generation,
other generations to follow.
Maybe it's dealing
with the poverty
that we find in too
many parts of our world.
Maybe it's dealing with some
of the social challenges
and conflicts that we
have in the war-torn areas
of the world.
But you want to
make a difference,
and I think that is fantastic.
And yes, you want a
good financial return
for your investments
and your contributions.
But notice, these
are mixed together.
And I think when we did
the interviews, when
we did the exercise
around asking, how
are your views similar or
different than your parents,
the dominant thing
that came through
in your qualitative
comments, to me,
was that you want many of the
same things as your parents--
respect, security in some
sense, financial security.
But you also want more.
You recognize you
are perhaps more
privileged than your
parents or grandparents
and that you are
in a position where
you can have an opportunity
to have a meaningful job,
make a meaningful contribution,
and really contribute
to improving society.
And so I think there's more
that you expect out of work
than perhaps prior generations.
Here is just a
couple of examples.
And I want to put a little
bit more substance on that pie
chart, because I think
it tells us something
about the complexities
of work today
and of the workforce today.
And this is one point
that someone made,
and I think it summarizes
that chart pretty nicely.
"I dream of a well-balanced work
and family environment, where
I can develop my
skills and put them
to service of my
community, as well as
to get a wage that allows me
to live decently and provide
for my future offspring."
So here we bring family
and work together.
We bring commitment
to an important cause,
but an expectation that I can
do this in a way that will
take care of my family needs.
Our MBA students
here in the classroom
had an assignment to go out
and talk to other workers,
to interview them and
do an audio recording.
And we received some fantastic
recordings and stories
from workers telling their
own story about work.
And I just want to
illustrate two of them
that I think help bring home
the complexity and the diversity
that we find in work experiences
and in our workforce today.
This one says-- it's an
immigrant from Ghana working
in a temporary job in
transportation and construction
and manufacturing services
and has had a variety
of these kinds of jobs.
And what is his aspiration?
It's very basic and very
simple for an immigrant.
He wants to finish school.
He wants to get a better job.
He wants to start a family.
And he wants to
live comfortably.
That's the immigrant story
that builds so many countries
around the world, where people
take the risks of moving
from their homeland to somewhere
else in search of a better
life.
And it's our
responsibility, therefore,
to make sure that people
who have that aspiration
can actually realize it.
And we appreciate the value
that they bring to our countries
when they come.
And I thought that was a
very interesting comment.
And this is one.
This might be one of
my most favorite ones.
It's from a 26-year-old
college graduate
who is an Uber
driver at the moment.
And just I'll read this because
it illustrates the complexity
of what's going on in
this individual's mind
and in his life in trying to
figure out where to go next.
And he's saying, what am I
looking for in the next job?
Well, I'm "looking for
a well-paying job--
over $15 an hour."
Whether we consider
that well paid or not
is another question, but
that's what his aspiration
is at the moment.
"Salary is definitely there, but
number one is the environment--
as long as I enjoy
what I'm doing--
be able to live your life
and enjoy what you are doing.
But now I'm finding that
it's really hard to live off
one job; I see lots of people
having to work two jobs.
For me, it's just to be
able to support yourself
and your family with one job."
Seems to me that's a very,
very basic simple aspiration,
that if we can't deliver on
that particular expectation,
there's something wrong
with our work systems.
There's something
wrong with our economy.
And there's something wrong
with the way in which we
are structuring work today.
If we can't really
provide an opportunity
to support yourself and
your family with one job,
we've got a lot more work to do.
These were just a
couple of the interviews
that came from our MBAs.
But I want to turn to the people
in the classroom and ask them.
Just very quickly, just give
a quick one minute or a one
sentence or two summary.
What surprised you when
you talked to workers?
Because I encouraged
the students
to go out and not
just talk to someone
who was very much like them, but
to talk to people [INAUDIBLE]
from a little background
[INAUDIBLE] occupation.
So just very quickly, let's
just get some statements
about what surprised you.
Leo's going to start us off.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I think for me it's
reading this and comparing
to what I had in my interview.
I actually interviewed
someone who
worked at management
consulting, which
is very high-prestige
profession, very well-paid.
And the thing they
complained was
balance between work
and personal life,
working 100 hours a
week and having to--
they wanted to quit
just to have more time
to spend doing the
things they liked
and being with their families.
So both on the top
and the bottom,
people are feeling the same
need of, like, maybe they're
overworking and, like,
too much pressure on them.
TOM KOCHAN: Yeah.
So here's this
concern of, I'm always
on the road or [INAUDIBLE].
What else did you hear?
AUDIENCE: So with the first
citation we had up there--
I was interviewing a
French retail worker.
And it was interesting to hear
how that worker didn't want
to use their nationality,
which could easily
be associated with
luxury products,
as their selling point.
So they were trying to
kind of break out of it,
and they recognized the value.
But just interesting
to hear how different
backgrounds and
nationalities can
influence how you approach
work, how you succeed at work,
and how you want to
be identified at work.
TOM KOCHAN: Yeah.
So here is someone [INAUDIBLE].
And the fact that this person
was a wine salesman, well,
we tend to think, French
wine, my goodness.
But he wanted to demonstrate
that he knew wine
not because he was
French and didn't
want to use that as
a marketing device.
He wanted to demonstrate he
really loves this cuisine.
He loves to do it.
He loves to sell it.
And he wants to have an impact.
What else?
Yeah, [? Cueto. ?] Go ahead.
We lost the-- here we are.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I
interviewed someone who
works with the state
of Massachusetts
on the theme of work balance.
He said something
interesting, that even
though a lot of times people
think working in government
doesn't pay well, the
work balance actually
comes into effect
because you're not
allowed to check your
emails when you go home.
So in the private
sector, you may
get a cell phone
and laptops and all
that, but somehow you're
expected to be on 24/7.
TOM KOCHAN: Yeah.
So this technology can either
be our ally or our worst enemy,
and they have a solution or a
strategy for dealing with it.
So that was very interesting.
Good.
[? Ladia. ?]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I interviewed a
immigrant worker.
She was a woman from Bangladesh
working for last 10 years
in the US.
And that surprised me when
I asked, what is your wish?
She said that, I
want that I could
save that amount
of money, that I
can afford a
two-bedroom house, and I
can keep my child with myself.
And she was already
doing two jobs.
And that made me think that
the price of the housing
is so high, and a person who
is working full time, and even
for the extra
time-- she was doing
two jobs-- it's
difficult for her
to maintain family life
and [INAUDIBLE] work.
TOM KOCHAN: Yeah.
So here's someone
who has a family, set
of responsibilities,
holding down two jobs,
just trying to
survive and get ahead,
another immigrant story that
is very common for people
who are trying to make it here.
Anyone else want to offer?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: For me, my interviewee
is a PhD student in the UAE.
And he has [INAUDIBLE]
for 12 years.
And what surprised me is that,
I'll also mention to you,
is that the labor union in
the UAE or the Arabic area,
most of the countries,
is illegal, which
is my first time to know that.
And previously, I
already heard the news
that the immigrant laborers,
like from Pakistan,
from India, they got
very low payment,
like it's about $200 US per
month probably, or even less.
But before that, I had no idea
that there was no protection
of these laborers.
And generally,
their visa is linked
to the employer, which means
the employer can easily
misuse their right to
force them to work hard.
TOM KOCHAN: Yes.
This is a big, big issue for
immigrants in many countries,
particularly in the Middle East.
I've spent some time
in Saudi Arabia trying
to work with the Minister
of Labor in Saudi Arabia
to change those, and
it's very difficult.
But here is a country
where worker rights
are very much suppressed.
And particularly
the vast majority
of the workforce in
the private sector
are immigrants from very
low-income countries,
and they're tied
to their employer.
So when we think about
the workplace today
and we think about
our aspirations,
we generally tend to
think about the fact
that we have a
free labor market.
We can move if things
are not satisfactory,
or we can raise our voice,
individually or collectively,
to try to change things.
But we have to understand that
a very large number of people
across the globe don't have
those very, very basic rights
or what the International
Labor Organization-- remember
Guy Ryder's introduction
to this course way back
in the first week,
the director-general
of the ILO in Geneva.
A core principle,
a core human right,
according to the International
Labor Organization,
a part of the UN, is
freedom of association,
along with freedom from
discrimination and from forced
labor and child labor.
So those are some
very, very basic things
that we expect in
the world of work.
But not all people and, in
fact, a very significant portion
of the workforce
across the globe
don't have these basic rights.
So we have to remember this
as we think about where we are
and how we advance from
the stage that we're at.
[? Shahid, ?] do you have a--
AUDIENCE: There was
a question on Twitter
where someone asked, do you
have an example of [INAUDIBLE]
country which is sort of
facilitating some of that,
making sure that some of these
[INAUDIBLE] sort of things
are not imposed on the
people, on the workers?
Do you have some good
examples [INAUDIBLE]?
TOM KOCHAN: Well,
there are examples
of countries that are struggling
with this and working on it.
One middle-income country that
is actually quite advanced
is Singapore.
And Singapore has a lot
of immigrant workers,
particularly in the
domestic service sector,
and they've had some scandals,
some terrible experiences.
But they have now imposed some
very strong legal constraints
and strong enforcement.
Because it's one
thing to have a law,
but it's another thing
to try to enforce it.
And so Singapore is
working to make progress
in this direction.
But I have to say,
in the Middle East
some countries are
doing a better job,
but there is a long,
long way to go.
And that's where
perhaps the issue
is most serious
and most profound
because the benefits
to migrant--
immigrant workers going
from Pakistan or Bangladesh
to the Middle East are
quite substantial if they
can stand the harsh
conditions of the work.
And the employers
in the Middle East
understand that there are real
advantages for people coming
to take that work,
and so therefore
that just feeds into some
of the more harsh rules.
I think we will see change.
Those of you who have been
reading the world news
have just heard
that Saudi Arabia
is trying to move away from some
of its dependence on the oil
industry.
Saudi Arabia has also
tried to introduce, slowly,
with the leadership of
their Minister of Labor
a number of years ago,
more rights for women,
because women don't have
many rights to drive a car
or to work in settings
where men are present.
That is slowly changing.
That's going to
take a long time.
But here, again, is an
example of a society that
has a set of values,
historical values, that
are very important to their
identity and their religion.
But as outsiders, we may have
some questions about them.
We have to understand
these countries
in their own cultural context.
But I do believe there are some
very basic core rights of work
that have to be respected
regardless of where people
work, how they work, who
they are, and who they work.
So I think this is a campaign.
It's something that we
can continue to work for.
So thank you for that question,
whoever posted it on Twitter.
OK.
Let's move on.
This is a good start.
We have an understanding,
a deeper understanding,
of what we are looking
from work and now a really
good discussion of what
people around the world
are experiencing as they try
to improve their situation.
We paid special attention
to history in this class.
And I want to thank one of
the participants in the class
for posting this great quote
from Thomas Jefferson, one
of our most famous presidents,
the third president
of the United States
and one of the authors
of the Declaration of
Independence for the United
States.
So Jefferson said that, "History
by appraising them of the past
will enable them"--
that is all of us--
--"to be a judge of the future;
it will avail us to learn from
the experience of other
times and other nations;
it will qualify us as judges
of the actions and designs
of men"-- that's a very
time-honored or an unhonorable
use of the word "men" but
that's the way he wrote--
and "it will enable us to
know the ambitions of others
even under every disguise it
may not assume; and knowing it,
to defeat its views."
Thomas Jefferson was
a student of history.
Thomas Jefferson
respected history.
We respect history
in this class.
Not to repeat it, not to try to
go back to the way things were,
but to learn from it
so that we can lay
a foundation for the future.
So we spent time here
in the United States
talking about this
foundation that
was laid in the 1930s
called the New Deal.
And we even celebrated
some of the people
who helped to bring about it--
a professor from the
University of Wisconsin
whose ideas led to
unemployment insurance
and led to Social
Security and led
to the passage of child
labor and minimum wage
legislation in that state
and in other states before we
got national legislation.
And to Frances Perkins,
the first woman
who was a member of a
president's cabinet.
President Roosevelt asked her
to be the Secretary of State.
And Frances Perkins said to the
president when he asked her,
are you sure you really want me?
Because if you are going
to put me in that office,
I'm going to bring my experience
to bring about Social Security,
some minimum wage, some
basic rights of unemployment
insurance to bear
at a national level.
Frances Perkins
observed firsthand
the terror of a factory fire
called the Triangle Shirtwaist
fire in New York City in the
earlier part of the century,
where over 100 women died
because the fire escapes were
locked as the fire burned
in that particular factory.
And that imprinted
her commitment
to make a better place for
work, a more safe place to work.
And as a result of
leadership and ideas
and commitment and a change
in politics in the 1930s,
we got the foundation
of the Social Security,
the Retirement Security Act
basically, the unemployment
insurance for the first time,
the ability to join a union
and engage in collective
bargaining protected
for the first time, and a
minimum wage and overtime
rules for the first time.
That foundation in
the United States
and comparable legislation
in other countries,
many in Europe before us,
some in Asia after us,
some still struggling
to put these kinds
of basic foundations and floors
on their conditions of work.
But it was that foundation
that allowed us to then build
what we talked about in several
sessions as the social contract
here in the United States
and in other places.
And so the question then
is, can we build on this?
Yes, this worked for
many years, and we'll
look at that in just a moment
just to refresh our minds.
But can we build
a new foundation?
If today's world has changed
as dramatically as we
have discussed it
throughout this course,
then it behooves us to ask,
what's the new foundation?
What's the new
body of legislation
that would lay the
framework for us
to advance and to deal with
some of the issues we're
going to talk about here
in just a few minutes?
So let's-- [? Adelie, ?] did
you have a question or comment?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Just a comment that,
like, [INAUDIBLE]
specifically said
that, in this country,
any business who is
depending on its existence
by paying less than
the living wage
should not have the
right to be in the US.
And he said that,
by the living wage,
I don't mean just
above existence,
like just [INAUDIBLE].
But I mean that it should
be a living [INAUDIBLE]
the decent wage.
So I mean, perhaps
in this course,
that's what we are
trying to stress,
that there should be a decent
living for the workers also.
TOM KOCHAN: Yeah.
No, absolutely.
He was a strong advocate
for worker rights,
for urging business to
provide a living wage
to get us out of the Great
Depression of the 1930s.
And it was that kind of
strong national leadership
that helped to
make this possible.
So let's look at what happened.
We've talked about
the social contract.
And if you look at this chart,
which we used at several points
in the course, it
shows, as you've
seen before, that from
the end of World War II up
through the 1970s
till about 1980,
wages and productivity
moved together in tandem.
That is, as the
economy got stronger,
the institutions of
collective bargaining,
the leadership of personnel
management and human resource
managers in our
large corporations,
made sure that wages were moving
up in tandem with productivity.
So workers shared, by and
large, in the benefits
of the economic growth.
But something happened,
as we all know,
in the late '70s
and the early 1980s
to break this relationship.
And that's when you see wages
flatlining and productivity
continuing to grow.
And that, my friends,
I think explains
a lot of the frustrations
that we are seeing here
in the United States play out
in our political debates today.
That workers today are
saying, we have not shared
or we have been
displaced, and our income,
which came from good jobs,
maybe manufacturing jobs
which have gone offshore or
been outsourced domestically,
or whatever happened to
them, changed by technology,
have not benefited from
a lot of these changes.
And so we are now
reaping the costs
of not addressing these
changes in the economy
so that people could keep
up with this process.
And so one of the things
that we did in the course
is we asked all of you, what
do you think about this?
Do you believe wages
and productivity
should go together?
And the vast majority,
over 80% of you, said yes.
But you're worried about it.
You're also realistic.
You know that the
world has changed.
You know that globalization
is more dominant now.
You know that technology
has eliminated
a lot of routine
jobs, as we covered
in later sections of the
class, and you've seen it
in your own communities.
We know that we're creating new
forms of work that don't always
provide some of the same
supports and benefits.
And so while you know that you
would like to see this happen--
and these comments come, again,
off the discussion board--
you're all worried about
how can we make this happen.
And I think the one
on the left really
captures the
sentiment of the class
as well as any that I saw
on the discussion board.
And it says, "I think
it's important to maintain
the productivity increases
aligned with raising wages.
If we, as a society,
continue to show only
huge social and
economic inequalities,
and that the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer,
then we will not be able to have
a successful and sustainable
society."
That's a powerful statement.
And if people really
feel that way, then
eventually they are going
to act to change this.
And it's our job to turn some
of this anger and frustration
into positive
actions for dealing
with this gap between
economic progress
for some but a lot of
people left behind.
So how do we do it?
We have to go beyond just
hoping that it changes
or wishing that it
changes or worrying
that we can't change it.
And we have to start
to address some
of the core causes
of the change.
And we spent some time talking
about, is this inevitable?
And we started with
the corporation.
What is the corporation for?
Is the corporation
simply an instrument
to maximize shareholder value?
Is the corporation
expected to be
held accountable for additional
interests in society,
for employees, for
their communities?
Well, we heard from one of
the most respected former CEOs
and business leaders
in the United States,
in fact, globally, of
the last generation--
John Reed, president
and CEO of Citicorp,
then went on to be president
of the New York Stock Exchange.
And that interview that
I did with John, which
I did a year ago, I
think that interview
has been replayed by more
business schools than anything
else from this course.
Because here's someone
who is so highly
respected and has lived
through the transition.
And John Reed's view reflected
the views of most people
in the online course.
And he basically said,
look, a corporation, yes,
has to achieve profits
and shareholder value.
That's beyond question.
But we also have to worry
about the customers.
We have to worry
about the employees.
And if we don't do that,
then, in the long run,
organizations are going
to face such a backlash.
And we're not going to prepare
the labor force for the future,
because corporations are
also training engines.
And he's very worried about
the workforce and the training.
That's why he was so
active in education,
both here at MIT as an
officer of our corporation
but also I know in
his private work
around the country and
indeed around the globe,
and trying to
advance particularly
technical education,
advance science, technology,
engineering, and math
education in our universities
and in our high schools.
So here is the challenge.
If we recognize--
and most of you said,
we expect corporations
to behave in ways
that respond to shareholders
and other stakeholders.
What do we do?
That's nice rhetoric.
But if all we do is
complain about it
or go out on the streets and
hold up a sign or a picket
sign, I suppose
that's a statement,
but that's not going
to get the job done.
So we spent a lot of time
talking about what to do,
and we used lots of examples.
And here's just a
few, and you all
heard about these
throughout the course,
as Costco compared to Walmart.
Costco, a retailer that does
invest in its employees, that
does go the high
road, as we call it,
that says we're going to
invest in our employees.
We're going to make
them more productive
than our competitors.
And by making them
more productive,
we can afford to pay
them a higher wage.
This is not charity.
This is the way we're
going to do business.
This is the way we're going
to meet our customer needs.
And it's been very successful
in doing so financially.
And it provides a high
level of customer service,
and it has a loyal customer base
and also provides good jobs.
And we compared
that with Walmart.
Walmart is worldwide, one of
the largest private employers
in the world perhaps,
certainly here in North America
it is and in many of the
countries represented
in this course.
And Walmart does a lot
of very good things
for the environment.
Walmart was one of
the first corporations
to respond when we had
this terrible Hurricane
Katrina in New Orleans in 2005.
And it sent, before
anybody asked it to do it,
trucks of water and
support and food
to help the victims
of that hurricane.
So Walmart does a
lot of good things.
But Walmart also competes on
the basis of just low prices
and low wages and keeping
unions out and in controlling
the workforce in
ways that creates
high levels of turnover, not
such good customer satisfaction
and service, but low prices.
And so here we have
the two comparisons
that allow us to say,
which one do we prefer?
Could Walmart improve
its organization
and its performance on the
employment side the same way
it has demonstrated it can
do on the environmental side
or on the operations
side, where it
is as good as any
company in the world?
If it did, perhaps we could have
a high road retail industry.
But it holds everybody else
down in the retail industry.
We used another example
in retail, a local one
here in the Boston and
New England region, one
that our colleague Zeynep
Ton did a very good video on,
called Market Basket.
And this has now
become kind of an icon
for a high road
retail firm, a firm
where the employees, the
high-level executives,
the store managers, the
clerks, the truck drivers,
the warehouse workers did
an unprecedented thing,
something I've never seen
in all the years I've
been working in this field.
I never saw a coalition like
that come together to say,
we are going to stand
up for a high road
company and a high road CEO who
was being fired by the board
so that they can
extract more money
for the owners of the company.
And for six weeks, they
rallied the employees.
They basically stopped the
business from functioning.
They had the loyal support
of their customers,
because their customers knew
what was at stake for them.
Because here's a
company that has
very low prices
but great customer
service, great community
involvement in stores
all over New England,
family relationships,
that people know each
other when they shop
and they know the employees.
The employees wear their
tenure in a little badge
on their shirt.
And this was all
going to go away.
And you saw how
the community, how
the media, how the
employees came together
to fight for good jobs
and a good company.
And in the end, the
board of directors
relented, and they
reinstated the CEO.
And that company now is not
only successful financially,
it's expanded.
The prices have remained low
relative to their competitors.
And in fact, if you want to go
and see a movie this weekend,
they're going to premier
a documentary here
in a local theater
in Somerville, which
is just near us here
off the MIT campus.
It's called Food
Fight, but it basically
tells the story
of the people who
were involved in that dispute.
It's a very powerful,
powerful movie.
I've seen it.
I don't get any
royalties on it, so this
isn't a commercial for it.
But it really is
the best documentary
of people who have
put their lives
and their jobs on the
line for something
they really believed
in, and it worked out
in a good way for them.
But there are other examples.
Southwest Airlines we've
used, Kaiser Permanente,
highly unionized.
Southwest is highly unionized.
Labor management partnerships,
where they are working together
to improve health care.
We know that the
bundle of practices
that are necessary
to make this work
move from good
operations strategy--
that is, you really need
to manage your inventory.
You need to manage
your operations.
You have to have good
efficient practices
if you're a manufacturer or
if you're a service provider.
And that has to be matched with
effective use of technologies,
but also training
of the workforce,
of respecting the
workforce, for asking
the workforce for their
engagement and their ideas
on how to improve operations
over time, for including
the concerns for work and family
and finding that balance that
makes the most sense for the
nature of the organization.
It means that you have to
have a business strategy that
supports innovation and
good customer service
and values those
kinds of features
as a way of doing business.
The way Southwest does
it, they turn those planes
around more quickly
than anyone else
when a plane lands,
from the time
it lands to the time it takes
off, because people are working
together in teams in
very flexible ways
and solving problems
for each other
and meeting customers' needs.
And so that's the
way in which we
know one can build a company
that works financially
for the share owners
and the investors
and also works for customers
and can work for employees.
But it takes a lot of hard work.
And so one of the
questions we always have
is, well, why is it--
why is it that it's
so hard to see that?
And is the privates--
or the public corporation
the only way to do it?
Some companies,
some organizations,
are turning to different
organizational forms
to make this happen.
And this is just
a sampling, and we
talked about these throughout
the class at various points
as well.
Many of you know about
Patagonia, this clothing maker.
And in fact, Patagonia--
I'll tell you a story
that's going on right now
here in one of our
communities northwest of here
called Lawrence, Massachusetts,
an old textile industry
town that is very highly
populated by immigrants now,
Latinos largely and people
from various parts of Latin
and South America.
And there was a plant there
that was privately owned.
It was called Malden Mills.
And in the 1990s-- and
it was owned by a fellow
by the name of Aaron
Feuerstein, who
had a very good relationship
with the workers,
with the community, with
the union in that plant,
providing decent jobs.
And they had a terrible fire.
And I think it was 1995 or
1997, the plant burned down.
And Aaron Feuerstein said,
we're going to rebuild it.
And by God, while
we're rebuilding it,
I'm going to make sure that
the employees still get paid.
And this made national news.
And he did it not
for the publicity.
He did it because he wanted
to hold onto that workforce.
And he was committed
to it, and he
knew that that
workforce had made
his family very prosperous.
And they rebuilt the
plant, made it more modern,
has succeeded over time.
When Feuerstein retired, it then
got bought by a private equity
firm.
That private equity
firm now wants
to close it down and move it
to another part of the country
or move it offshore.
And so the employees
and their union
have turned to Patagonia,
because they make Polartec,
and Patagonia is a big
purchaser of Polartec,
and said to Patagonia, why
don't you buy this plant?
Why don't you buy
this business and keep
us going in a viable way?
So here's another case where
some choices about how do we
sustain decent
quality employment
with a very good business,
with a very good product,
that is serving
lots of customers
in very innovative ways
and in various kinds
of sport clothing.
Can we find a way to
sustain that business?
I don't know what
the answer will be.
But it's playing out
quietly at the moment
about 40 miles from here,
from the MIT campus.
We have other examples--
Mondragon.
It's a Spanish co-operative
that built over time
to become a major
industrial enterprise
in that part of the
world and, in fact,
has operations around
the world, including
here in the United States.
Employee-owned companies.
We used a couple of
different brewery examples.
And this one happens
to be a local one--
Harpoon.
I put it up there because
I tend to like their beer,
and I like the fact that
they are also employee-owned.
But it's a fine organization.
Again, this is not a
commercial for their beer.
But if you ever have
the opportunity,
I wouldn't discourage
you from trying it.
It's well-made.
And then my favorite example--
people here a little
sick of hearing it--
about my Green Bay
Packer football team.
But here's a little town,
Green Bay, Wisconsin,
that supports a football
team because the football
team is owned by the community.
There's no way that that
football team would have lasted
from 1927, when they were
first formed, and stayed
in Green Bay up until today
and will stay there forever,
because the community owns
it, and it can't be sold.
It can't be sold to
some investor who
wants to have a hobby because
he or she's made their fortunes,
and therefore they just
want a football team.
This is something
that builds community
and the loyalty to
that organization
and to that football
team, carries on
even for those of us who have
moved away for many years.
So we can build
these organizations.
We can use different kind
of governance models,
we can use different kinds
of business strategies,
but we have to respect
the need to respect
the rights of employees, respect
the need to manage in a way
that makes the organization
successful, as well
as responsive to
employee concerns.
And so you have strong views.
Just as you had strong
views about the corporation,
there was a lively
debate on the discussion
board about these high road
firms and low road firms.
And you recognize,
this quote recognizes,
that some firms have a natural
affinity to being a high road
firm, because it's consistent
with their business strategy.
That is, they say
here that if you
want to compete on the
basis of innovation,
and that's part of the
core business strategy,
then you're more likely
to be a high road firm.
But what about firms that don't
have that business strategy?
How are we going to
get them to do it,
and how are we going to get more
firms to compete on this basis?
Well, that's the big question.
The answer that comes
here is it's only
going to come if there's
pressure from employees.
If employees themselves
start to raise their voices,
and how to do this.
So I would ask you, I would
ask the people in this room,
if you were to move
forward and try
to move us to see
high road firms spread
more rapidly and more
broadly cross our industries,
so that more people
in our economy
could benefit from
these strategies, what
needs to be done?
And if you have ideas online,
put them on the discussion
board, send us your comments
on Twitter, but this, to me,
is the most
challenging question.
As you think about your
answer, some of you
recall that two weeks ago,
we were fortunate enough
to have the Secretary
of Labor, Tom Perez,
come and speak to our
MIT Sloan School MBAs,
and he posed that question.
And he challenged the
future leaders in the MBA
and in the Sloan community
to manage in the ways
that we're talking about here.
But privately, as
we talked about it,
he too, asked me and
others, what can we do?
What can we do to spread these
kinds of practices more widely?
And so I'm asking you.
Leo?
AUDIENCE: I think there's
one thing that [INAUDIBLE]
additional policies.
Some policies are necessary, by
just worker voice and stronger
unions, but also, even
higher minimum wage.
If minimum wage is higher,
and [INAUDIBLE] salaries would
be higher, that put
pressure on the companies
to train their workers and
have more productive workers.
Because if you're
going to have--
you're going to be forced
to pay a better salary,
you're going to try to
extract that value that you
obtaining, the only way you can
do is by training them more.
TOM KOCHAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: And having them like--
being better.
And you're also giving
workers protection
from being laid
off so easily, so
that also commits the
company a little bit more
to their workers.
So in that sense, you
can create maybe a more--
TOM KOCHAN: Yeah.
So Leo is reflecting a
view that many people hold,
that we got to bring up
the floor of the low road,
and we've got a higher
minimum wage, stronger
enforcement of other
Labor Standards perhaps,
that's going to create
some incentives.
You know, Wal-Mart did raise
its wages by $1 an hour
above the minimum wage in
response to employee pressure.
Now what that requires
McDonald's to get
the return on that
increased wage,
is they've got to
start to train people.
They've got to hold
on to their employees
more, for a longer
period of time.
Whether they will do that
or not, I don't know.
But absolutely it sets in
motion some of the dynamics that
create a stronger incentive.
Greg?
AUDIENCE: This is
going back to stuff
we talked about in the
beginning of the semester,
but I think getting the right
investors on board, if you--
TOM KOCHAN: Uh huh.
AUDIENCE: --need
investors is critical.
TOM KOCHAN: Good.
AUDIENCE: And I think that
a lot of the [INAUDIBLE]
at MIT where people
talk about making sure
if you're an early
stage [INAUDIBLE]
get investors that are
aligned what you want.
I think too often,
we see investors
that push companies to
try scale really quickly--
TOM KOCHAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: --and a lot of
that necessitates sacrifices
that this quote kind of talks
about, but I don't think you
have that motivation,
unless you have
someone else who kind of
can give you that pressure
and try to force you to take it.
TOM KOCHAN: So picking your
investors is really important.
And in one of the
videos that we did
for the course, Scott
Stern, one of our colleagues
who teaches
entrepreneurial strategy,
is one of our best people in
this field, makes that point.
And in fact, there'll be a
slide that will illustrate
this just in a few minutes.
But absolutely.
Picking your investors
is really critical.
Ben?
AUDIENCE: I wonder
how hard it is
to change the
momentum of something
like Wal-Mart, who's
publicly traded.
But for example, with
Harpoon it had the option
of being bought out,
and they consciously
made a decision as
privately held company
to move towards employee owned.
So is it too hard to
manipulate Wal-Mart,
and should we just
focus on advancing
the Costcos, and the Market
Baskets, and the Harpoons,
and the Allagashes of the world,
and just kind of let Wal-Mart
reap what it sows with its
illegal labor practices.
TOM KOCHAN: Well,
that's a good question.
I'm not sure that
I have the answer.
Should we let Wal-Mart alone
because it's the toughest nut
to crack in some ways, or
because it's the biggest--
it would have the
biggest effect,
should we put resources there.
I do believe that it's a sign
of some mental problems when
you keep beating yourself
against a wall, right?
And I think if you
can't really change it,
then you have to go where you
can really bring about change.
Yes, we should perhaps
continue to put pressure
on companies like
Wal-Mart, but perhaps we
have to go where the
opportunities are.
And that's why
courses like this,
educating the next
generation of leaders, is so,
I think, important.
Because we can
make a difference.
And if we can get people
to think about the choices
and know that
they've got choices,
and recognize that there are
some directions that they can
take their company, and as
you go out into the companies
that you will be employed in and
the people in the online course
go out and work in a
variety of settings,
you can be raising
these questions.
And in fact, I'll
tell you a secret.
There are some Sloan School
graduates in some companies
not to be mentioned,
but similar to what
we're talking
about here, who are
raising those questions
today, and bringing some
of their executives back to
campus to see if they can learn
more about what would it
take, is it possible to do it.
So I'm maybe an internal
optimist on this.
I'm not naive, it's
a big road to travel,
but I think we can
make a difference.
And so I want to go where the
opportunities are, perhaps more
than where the
resistance is greatest.
Well, this is just one way of
proceeding with the high road
strategies that are
really important,
there are opportunities
for moving forward.
And you had-- the folks
in the online course--
have had the experience
of testing this idea.
Because one of the
assignments was
to go out and interview
someone in an organization,
in an industry of
interest to you,
and you asked them a
series of questions
that come from the
research that's
been done on what does it
take to build a high road,
high performance
work organization,
and what does it take
to meet the aspirations
of the workforce to have
satisfying work experiences.
And that battery of
questions then ended
with a very simple
question to the student who
was collecting the data on
the basis of an interview
with an employee, and
said to the student,
if you were offered a
job in this organization,
would you take it or not.
And the numbers, the raw
numbers were 60% said yes,
but 40% said no.
I didn't hear that
this was the kind
of organizational
environment that
would allow me to use my skills,
or to have a satisfying work
experience.
That's a pretty
remarkable distribution,
that 40% after hearing about an
organization, say no thank you,
I don't think I would
take a job there.
I think we've got a
lot of work to do.
But the good news
in this is that you
do a little bit of
statistical analysis,
and you ask do these high
performance, high road
characteristics and
good job characteristics
predict whether someone
would take a job or not.
The good news for employers
is that if you provide
these kinds of opportunities
and features in your workplace,
you have a 75% chance
of attracting the talent
that you need.
That people will accept a job,
it's not 60%, it's now 75%.
That's a substantial
change, and so the good news
is that firms can attract
the kind of talent
and perhaps retain
that they need to support a
high performance organization,
if they invest and engage in
the right set of practices.
So that's another
reason why I think
we need to do more of this.
We need to keep
asking about what's
going on in organizations.
There is a growing number
of online platforms
and various kinds of use
of information technology
that we'll talk about in just
a moment that is providing
more information on firms.
Glass Door is probably
the best known,
where it collects employee
ratings of their employer.
Well, we need to use
that kind of data--
those data to understand
what is the difference
between an attractive
place to work
and a less attractive
place to work, and then
use our skills to move to
where the good jobs are,
so that we discipline, and again
bring up the lower road firms.
So I'm encouraged by the
good jobs survey exercise.
I hope people do that,
maybe informally.
You don't have to go out and
ask 25 questions every time,
but you can ask
the key questions,
because you know what
they are, and you
know what you're
looking for, and you
know what's really important.
Then we came to this
question about well, unions.
Unions have this great
phrase in the United States.
In the 20th century,
they say, we're
the organization that
brought you the weekend,
and they're right.
They're the organization that
really negotiated more time
off, holiday pay, vacation
pay, sick leave, weekend
over time rates for working
the unattractive hours,
or working more than
40 hours, and so on.
And so unions have a very long
history in the United States
and around the world for
improving wages, hours,
and working conditions
and helping to lift up
the standards in our
economies, but we all know that
particularly here
in the United States
but in many countries
around the world,
unions are on the decline.
And in fact, many people,
probably in the online course,
never even thought
much about unions.
Many of the people here
at the Sloan School.
It's not on the front
burner of their minds
to think about unions as a
force for economic advancement,
in our economy or in their
particular work lives.
So we felt it was important
to engage this question.
Is there a future?
Do we still need them?
And the views were quite
diverse and a good discussion.
But I think there's a dominant
view that, well, unions
played an important
role in the past
in the way in which
they function,
and they had some
negative features as well.
They brought maybe
too much rigidity,
and some work rules that
impeded productivity,
and that continue to impede
productivity in some cases.
They were resistant to
change, because people
got used to the way in
which they were working
and to the benefits and to their
control over job opportunities
and so on.
They restricted access to
union jobs in some cases,
to their relatives or
people who looked like them.
And so there's a history of
discrimination in some unions.
That is not a very
attractive part
of the history of labor either.
So unions have a positive and
a negative historical setting--
or historical record that
we need to understand.
But the question is what
will replace this void,
or fill this void, that's
now left in the United States
and in some other countries
as unions decline?
Is there a way to revise
unions, rebuild them,
to create organizations
or entities that advocate
for workers in a modern way?
That was a source of discussion.
It's a source of
debate in this country,
and in many countries
around the world.
And basically, I think
most people in the course
have come to the conclusion
that yes, there is a role,
but it can't be just, as I put
it in the textbook, your father
or your grandfather's union.
Because it was mostly a male
dominated labor movement.
It no longer, by the way, is.
We're now in the United
States at just about 50%
of union members are
women as well as men.
And so it's changed over time,
but that's kind of the history.
But there's a recognition
that unions have to change.
There seems to be, it says
here "a conscious effort
to revitalize the way
that unions work in order
to meet the needs of the
most vulnerable workers
in recent years," particularly,
"in a globalized world."
So we're seeing
unions try to work
to deal with the terrible
problems that have occurred,
for example, in
Bangladesh, where
the first terrible factory fire
that took over 100 workers'
lives, and then the terrible
factory collapse that
took over 1,000 workers' lives
in Bangladesh, where standards
were not being attended to.
And so out of that has come
a global effort of unions
from Europe and from
around the world to say,
we need to work together with
companies in something that's
called the Accord, that
is, a negotiated agreement
for arbitration, for
safety provisions,
for safety inspections,
and for workers to have
a voice in that society.
Long way to go on
that, and in fact,
some American
corporations say we
want to address
these issues, but we
don't want to include
unions in that process.
So there is a parallel
effort called the Alliance,
with firms like the Gap and
Wal-Mart and others from the US
that are going it alone.
I don't know which
way is the best.
I'm not an expert
on Bangladesh, I've
only been there on one
very, very short visit,
so I wouldn't make a judgment
of what the right strategy is.
But here we have efforts
to try to do something
about global labor
standards by bringing
about some coalition of
the local organizations,
the local unions to
the extent that they
exist, international
unions working
with companies and with brands
to try to enforce standards
in those factories.
We talked about
Nike in the course,
we talked about how they
went through this process.
We talked about Apple's
struggles in China
and the suicides and
the terrible conditions
in organizations like Fox Con.
This is the front line of
worker voice and representation,
where we have to invent new
ways to make things work.
We also talked about the role of
labor management partnerships.
We've been privileged to
work with Kaiser-Permanente
for several decades now, in
helping to understand and study
the labor management
partnership they put in place,
and to work with
them to improve it.
Because all of
these institutions
are sort of fragile,
and there are always
tensions that are involved.
But here's an organization
that has worked with its unions
in health care.
And now on the
front lines you now
have 3,500 what they
call unit based teams.
Teams of employees, doctors,
nurses, technicians, service
employees, people who--
the janitors in the
organization work to say
how can we improve operations?
How can we reduce
injuries-- back injuries
for the workforce?
How can we reduce the
infections that we sometimes
find in hospitals?
What are we doing to
change the operation,
to serve our customers,
to use technology
to make sure that we're checking
on our clients or our patients
out there, and saying gee,
I looked on your record
and I noticed that
you haven't been
in to fill your
prescriptions, or you
haven't come in for your
scheduled appointments.
What's going on, and how can
we get those issues addressed
more effectively?
Working in teams, together,
labor and management
saying this is part
of how we're going
to create world class
health care delivery, and at
the same time, then have
industry leading wages.
And so there are
ways to do this.
We've learned from
organizations like Saturn that
started that way, but didn't
get the kind of support
we've learned from Kaiser.
We need more of those
kinds of organizations
according to many of you.
But you're also thinking
more creatively.
And there was a
lively discussion--
I couldn't pass
putting this concept
of a digital union, which came
right off the discussion board.
That created quite
a set of comments
over the course of the term.
And basically by
digital unions, we're
really talking about
ways to use information.
To use online platforms
the way businesses
are using them, to
share information.
What-- where are
the good jobs, where
are there not such good jobs.
How can we mobilize in China?
The way workers mobilize today
is through their smartphones.
They don't have
independent unions,
but they do have the
technology, and they
use that to build
their own network when
they feel most aggrieved and the
need to do something about it.
Now they have to
often do something
in a pretty spontaneous
way, and sometimes
in a very strong
resistance, sometimes
even in a violent
way, and sometimes
even holding the
plant manager hostage
in his or her own facility until
something can be negotiated.
But they're using
technology to try
to find new ways of
meeting worker needs.
Then there are other
organizations that we cited.
Different kinds of organizations
that aren't even called unions.
Some of them use the
term, but they're really
outside of the traditional
form of unions.
This one up in the upper
left hand corner here,
Restaurant Opportunities
Center, was cited in the course
a number of times, but
it's worth focusing on,
because it's a very
interesting organization that
came out of a tragedy.
It was formed after
our terrible experience
in September 11th, when
the Twin Towers in New York
collapsed from a
terrorist attack.
And out of that,
there was a restaurant
called the Windows on the
World at the top that obviously
collapsed with it, and many
employees died in that tragedy.
And so this
organization was formed
to try to deal with the
families and to help people cope
with that terrible disaster.
And what it's evolved
into is an organization
that works to both improve
job conditions for people
in restaurants, but also
to publicize good practices
for sustainable food,
and for food preparation,
and for the way in which
the workforce is treated,
the way in which the
customers are treated.
They encourage customers
to rate not only
the quality of the food, but
also the quality of the working
conditions, and ask about
it in the restaurants.
And they're working
to stay outside
of the traditions
of labor relations,
to find new ways
to train employees,
to provide information
on where good jobs are,
to make sure that they are
taking care of the safety
and health and providing
more information,
and working with
restaurant owners.
They are working with some of
the most innovative restaurant
owners in New York
and in San Francisco
and in other country--
other cities in
the United States,
to promote this as part of
their good company, good job
strategy.
And so this is just
another way in which
creative minds, young people,
in this case, young people
and immigrants working
together, largely, to say we
can find ways to do this
in a modern fashion that
is responsive to both
consumers, to employees,
and to the businesses
that operate.
So I think we're in
an interesting time.
Will these grow to be large
enough to have an effect?
I don't know, but I think
it's really up to all of you,
all of you, wherever you
happen to be in the world,
to invent the kinds
of organizations that
work effectively for you in
the kind of work settings
that you find yourself today.
And out of that will come some
models that will grow, perhaps
over time, and have an effect.
Well, we didn't just talk
about what others need to do.
We spent a good deal of time
talking about what individuals
need to do.
And we emphasize, obviously,
education as a cornerstone,
as a necessary
condition, but we also
emphasize the need
to be proactive
and engage in a career
planning exercise.
And so one of the
assignments was
to fill out the
online questionnaire
provided by the
Department of Labor
and it's vocational and
career planning tool, which
is just a standard one.
It's not any better,
I don't think,
or any worse than what
you find elsewhere.
The advantage is
it's free, and that's
why we used it, because
we didn't want to have
to have people pay for it.
But it was the starting point.
And out of that
completing that, it
provides information on
what one's aptitudes are,
what they might be good at,
what jobs and occupations match
those aptitudes very well,
what levels of education
are needed to get
to different levels
of the occupational structure
in that particular area,
and that provides an
opportunity to say
I can now make a roadmap for
how to go from where I am
to realizing what I want to do.
But we also asked people
to go out and talk
to people in those occupations
to get a firsthand sense of it.
So that they have a more
personalized view of what is it
that this job is
really all about.
And I think when I read
the responses, that's
where the learning really
started to take place.
And so the ability to go
out and engage with people
and really learn from
their experiences
is so critical to making
these career planning
guides come to life.
And look at the interesting mix
of jobs and occupations here.
I got a kick out of--
this is only a sample.
I just took some of the kind
of more interesting ones.
I guess they're all interesting,
but we have everything
from engineers and HR managers
and labor leaders and artists
and futurist.
Someone's going to-- is very
interested in being a futurist.
Holacracy consultant.
Anyone know what
whole holacracy is?
Probably not.
Well, holacracy is basically
organizational consultant
who works to share
power and authority
throughout the
organization, and to try
to reduce or even completely
get rid of hierarchy.
It's very controversial.
It has some very
strong advocates
and it has some
very strong critics,
but here's someone who
is really committed to it
and is going to go out and
wants to make a career of it,
and I applaud that energy.
A sports agent.
Psychometrician.
Technical writers,
artists, graphic artists.
So these are jobs--
these are all jobs
that people will
feel that they will find
what they really want to do.
And I want you to
keep these in mind
when we think about
in two slides down
the road here, about
the role of technology.
Because one of the big
worries in this course that
was voiced by so many
people, is what's
going to happen to our jobs
as technology comes along.
So I want to come
to that in a moment.
But look at, these
are jobs that are not
going to necessarily
go away and not
going to be taken over by robots
or artificial intelligence
in the near future.
They will be influenced
by them, for sure,
but we'll come to
that in a moment.
What are some of the themes
that came up in the career
development planning
process, this
is just a sampling from both
this year and last year.
The themes were almost
identical across the two years.
Very strong emphasis on
getting the credentials,
getting some stamp of approval
that I've got the skills,
that my customers can
trust me to come in and do
that work in someone's house,
or in community, or in taking
care of people in my family.
And so that's a
growing recognition
that that's important.
The importance on having
networks, and building
these networks so that they know
where the good opportunities
are and have access to them.
Emphasis on lifelong
learning and emphasis
on courses like this, that we
can use this online technology
perhaps to augment
the basic education
over the course of time to
support the lifelong learning
process.
And then recognition that people
will have to keep their skills
current, because they will be
changing careers and moving
across occupations
most likely over time.
And then finally,
this really important
point that sometimes the
career planning process doesn't
pay enough attention
to, that we don't make
these decisions in isolation.
We live in a community, we live
in a family, we have partners,
we have children,
and many of us have
children or other
relatives who depend on us.
Sometimes elderly parents
who need to be cared for.
And so as we make
these plans, one
of the requests in
the planning exercise
was don't just tell
us what you want
to do, but make sure
that you tell us
how it will affect everyone
else in your immediate family
or social setting.
And so that's an important
part of this career planning.
I think we can do this.
I don't believe that we
should overdo career planning.
We can't predict the
future completely,
and we shouldn't be so
determined that there's
only one course for the future.
But we should plan to be
ready to take advantage
of opportunities
when they come along,
and know which directions
we want to go in and not
be afraid to take those
steps when an opportunity is
open to us.
So the career planning and
the personal development plan
process in this course was
a vital part of what we did.
But then we come
to this question,
and this is a great frame.
I wish I could take time
take credit for this,
will technology eat our jobs?
But I didn't invent that term.
I did a little bit
of a Facebook chat
with a very talented
leader from Sama group.
Her name is Leila Janah,
and she runs an organization
that really works
with low income people
all over the globe to try to
help them to use technology
to improve their livelihood,
and to gain access
to better opportunities.
And so she raised the question,
and we had this discussion,
will technology eat our jobs.
We took a pretty strong
position in this.
And here we are at
MIT, and we have
some of the people who are
known for being some of the more
pessimistic, and we have
some people who are known
for being more optimistic.
We've got 'em all.
At MIT, I always
say, that if you--
we have 1,000 faculty members
and on any given issue,
those 1,000 faculty
members will have
at least 3,000 points of view.
And on this, I think, we can
see people all over the place,
because we don't really know.
The serious answer is
we don't know how rapid
or how broad scale artificial
intelligence, machine learning,
and all of these other things
are going to take over jobs.
But we know that if we don't do
anything, if we let it happen,
then we're at the risk
of the worst scenario.
But if we use technology
to augment work,
to augment and strengthen
the role of human judgment,
then we might be able to
have the best of both worlds.
And that's what even the IBM
Watson creators emphasized here
at MIT in a technology day
a couple of months ago.
And so we can do this.
We will have displacement.
There's no question that jobs
are going to be displaced.
The question is are we going
to be ahead of the curve
and really work to make
sure that we take care
of those people
who are displaced,
provide them opportunities
to move to where the job--
the good jobs are,
make sure that they've
got the skills built up
over time so that they
can make those changes, and
then get on with this process.
So I think we can use it.
I think we're going to see
more of these workers centered
apps that help us
adapt to technology.
I used the example,
we had an interview
with Sherpa Share,
the founders that
use the Uber technology
to share information
with the drivers on what
their real earnings are,
and now we're seeing drivers use
that app in new creative ways,
and other competing
apps are also out there,
even since we did that interview
a couple of months ago.
So I'm excited about the use
of technology to improve work,
but we've got to harness it.
We've got to be proactive if
we're going to be successful.
And what about entrepreneurship?
And again, there's a lot of
hyperbolic entrepreneurship.
That all new jobs are
created by startups.
Well, that's not quite true,
but a large number of new jobs
are created by startups.
So the importance of
startups, the importance
of entrepreneurship,
is beyond question.
We've got to make
sure that we have
a healthy growth
of new enterprises,
but we've got to do this
in a more inclusive way.
We've had terrible
scandals, and again, I'm
glad it's all over the news
these days, about how male
dominated Silicon Valley
is with its startups,
and how difficult it is
for women to move to higher
levels of leadership in
that part of our growing
sector of the economy.
And how difficult it is
for women to get money
from venture capitalists.
Well, we've got to change that
and build a more inclusive
capitalism if we are
going to be successful,
and in fact we know some things.
And so that's where
the Hitachi foundation
has been so successful,
in building a program
to help young entrepreneurs
to find those investors,
to pick those investors, as Greg
said earlier in this session
this afternoon, to make sure
that they pick investors that
are supportive of
growth opportunities.
We didn't use this
little example,
but I like it, because maybe
I like the name, called Beepi.
But Beepi is an online
used car business.
Started in San
Francisco, spreading
to other parts of the country.
We used it in our on
campus course as a case,
and so our students in the
room here are familiar with it.
But basically Beepi faced
this question, who would you
buy a used car from?
Do you want to buy it from
someone who is a full time
employee, who was signing
off and certifying
that this car has
been inspected,
this car has been
repaired, this car is safe,
and this car is worth the
price that is being asked,
or do you want to
buy it from someone
who doesn't have that same kind
of commitment, is just hired
as a contractor to go
through the motions to do it?
And Beepi faced investors
with debates about that,
and they went in the direction
of hiring and staying
with a business
strategy that says
we think trust is so important,
and quality is so important,
that we're going to
keep the full time jobs
with decent wages and benefits.
Now that's a choice that
young firms also can make,
but I am under no
illusion of the pressures
that startups face
to conserve costs,
because they don't
have much money,
and they don't have
a lot of resources.
So it's very difficult. But
if we don't imprint good jobs
right at the
beginning, it's going
to be very hard to bring
them in a little bit later.
So making sure that we
worry about inclusive
entrepreneurship and
inclusive capitalism
right from the beginning is
very important. [? Astrid? ?]
AUDIENCE: I was
just thinking, you
talk about the US
and the unions,
where [INAUDIBLE]
declined made the most.
One place where I feel
that the US can help us
in other parts of the
world is about taking risk.
Because here, if you're an
entrepreneur, you go for it
but you fail, maybe
because the technology
wasn't such a good
idea as you hoped for,
you have a legal system,
an environmental--
and like social ecosystem, but
that you go from [INAUDIBLE].
I think in lots of other
places in the world,
you've got two red lines
on you, and you're a loser.
And the funny part is
you are hidden away,
because you're a loser.
So think there, there is a
lot to gain with technology,
but also [INAUDIBLE]
here in America,
that you can help us in
the rest of the world
to be more entrepreneurial,
and to try.
TOM KOCHAN: I think that's
a very important point,
I'm glad you made it.
In the online course,
there's also an essay
from one of our Sloan graduates
from a number of years ago,
John Jacques Degroof,
who's written
about European entrepreneurship,
and he works on this in Europe.
And he's lamenting
the fact that Europe
is so slow to have that kind
of infrastructure, risk taking,
and support for
entrepreneurs, and says we've
got to really change that.
So he's reinforcing
the important point
that you made, and I think
it's worth paying attention
to some of the strengths that we
have here, as we move forward.
Well, you went through this
very difficult, challenging,
and for many of you,
rewarding experience
of saying all right, enough
of this talk about it.
Enough of this reading about
it, enough of the watching
boring videos.
Let's try to negotiate the next
generation's social contract.
And so I applaud the energy
that you put into it,
those that participated, and
our colleagues here on campus
who helped to facilitate it.
And so I just want to share a
little bit of the settlements
and what you came away
from that exercise with.
It's a difficult exercise to do.
It's challenging because of
the differences in time zones
and so on, but I
think it's worth
doing, perhaps maybe in some
modified way, some of you
some good suggestions.
And look, we again had a
very broad distribution.
We had 44 countries
participating
in this experience,
a nice broad array.
And here's some
of the priorities
that you chose to focus on.
And there were a set
of, as you recall,
workforce development,
compensation fairness,
representation, organizational
performance, family
and community, and basically
not one of those dominated.
There was a good
distribution of priorities.
Everyone recognized the
importance of all of these.
There was clearly a higher
preference for workforce
development, and
a little bit more
for fairness and
nondiscrimination,
but the varied
interests said just what
you said early on in
the course about how
important multiple things
are to you in the workplace.
And so lifelong
learning dominated,
voice and representation,
the concern for productivity
and flexibility in
organizations dominated,
and work and family
came through as well.
And these are just some numbers.
I'm not going to
go through these,
they just reflect basically
what I said a minute ago,
because we're running a
little bit short on time.
But let's look at
what you agreed to.
Well, we had about
157 agreements.
Some of them were two party,
some were three party,
some were four party.
But across those clusters,
what you did is you
embodied the knowledge
of the high performance
work organizations.
You said we can't just
focus on training,
and many of your
agreements had training
combined with performance.
Training combined
with compensation.
Training combined with
making sure it was inclusive.
Some of the European
examples said
we're even going to find ways
to bring it to the platform
economy, and see if
we can't bring some
of our training, experience,
and our representative models
into that sphere.
And so a very strong emphasis
on lifelong learning,
on career planning, the
notion that people should
have representation, emphasis on
partnerships, strong commitment
to flexibility in
organizations, strong commitment
to profit sharing.
That came through in many
of these agreements as well.
And so I think you found ways
to reach across interest group
lines to find ways to
find common ground.
Now if you can do
it in this exercise,
then perhaps why can't we do
it in our broader societies?
I would urge everyone
to take the same issues
and move them to other settings.
So where did we end up?
Well the last thing
we asked is what
are the messages to the
next generation leaders, HR
professionals, labor educators,
and government officials?
And our friends at Cornell
helped us out on the HR side.
So my good friend Lee
Dyer, who led that class,
and his students provided
these next three slides
on what do they see,
because they are
moving into this profession.
So what is it that they see as
important for the HR profession
to attend to?
And they emphasize three themes,
globalization, technology,
and demographics, and
on the basis of that
came up with a set
of slides and points
on what it means
for recruitment.
That they have to
recognize that there
has to be a good fit
between the competencies,
the organization needs, and
what employees need to bring.
They need to develop new
sets of technical knowledge,
emphasizing the technical
and STEM skills,
but also combining that
with problem solving,
and being able to work
collaboratively in teams.
So they embody the
integration of technology
and organizational skills
and understanding the need
to be responsive to
people's differences
in culture and backgrounds.
So I think on the
recruitment side,
that's a really
powerful set of points.
On the globalization side,
they saw the positives
and the negatives.
That yes, globalization
creates an opportunity
to compete for talent
all across the world,
and at the same time,
provides more diversity
that we need to
manage effectively,
but it also provides
some low wage havens,
and that's going to put pressure
on our compensation structure.
So they were quite realistic
in having to manage
the tensions of globalization.
And on technology,
it came back again
to emphasize the complimentary
nature that technology can
play, if they are proactive.
And if there's one message
to the HR community, in fact,
I delivered it this morning
to a group of HR professionals
in talking about
these issues, is
that they have to get out
in front of technology.
They have to be part of
the technology designers
and enablers to make work really
complements to technology.
And I think that's an
opportunity for the HR
profession.
And then they commented
as well on demographics,
along the lines that
we've talked about
for mentoring the next
generation workforce and so on.
So thank you, to our colleagues
at Cornell for those inputs.
But you also raised in your
own conversations issues
around implications
for worker advocates,
for needing to listen
to the workforce,
to learn from the workforce,
to build the new organizations,
not to be just captivated by
the way in which we did things
in the past.
To build on the
strengths of the past,
but to look to the
future, and particularly
to use information
technologies as building
new sources of power.
And for those of us in
the education community,
emphasizing we've got to
be more creative in using
all this technology, online
learning, and other mechanisms
to provide good guidance for
the next generation workforce,
and to provide
opportunities for continuing
to learn as we go along.
And then the toughest
nut, obviously,
is breaking the gridlock that
we find in the United States
and in some other countries
over national politics.
And here we emphasize
right from the beginning
that the lessons always come
from the local level first.
And so if we can build
on the innovations that
are happening that we've talked
about throughout this course
at the local level,
then maybe someday
soon our national leaders will
wake up and say maybe it's time
for us to start
working together.
So our bottom line message to
the next generation workforce,
to all of us, and
to all of you, I
guess I'm not the next
generation workforce,
but you are the next generation
workforce, is education.
Preschool, formal schooling,
and lifelong learning.
Education throughout
one's life, making
sure you explore,
but don't become
a victim of too tight a career
plan, but take opportunities
when they are available.
Keep those skills current, work
together, keep your resume up
to date, and one foot in
the external labor market
to use that as a source of
power, and get involved.
And together, if there's
a bottom line here,
we can shape the future of work.
So where are we going?
Once again, we emphasize
the high road importance,
rebuild bargaining power, get
the parties working together,
and then let me give
you the real bottom line
from two students from
our discussion board.
And I'll just read these
and end on this note.
And one said, "Taking
this course has
given me hope that the
future of work and the path I
wish to take after college.
The future of work
depends on the mindset
of individual workers."
Of all of you.
"If the workers are hardworking
and have confidence,
the future of work will
toil in their favor."
I think that's a
beautiful phrase
and I appreciate the
author's offering it.
And then one that
came just today.
"I came away feeling a personal
'call to action' to help shape
the Future of Work myself--
that indeed, the Future
of Work is up to us.
We have do-- we have--
we do have the power to
shape the Future of Work
by bringing together
all the stakeholders."
These are the bottom line
messages of this course.
This is what we all put
all this energy, all of you
put all the energy you put into
it, and the online version,
and our friends here on campus.
And I think together we can
shape the future of work,
so we just need to move forward.
We will put all of this material
online, it will stay online.
And you'll be encouraged to
come back and use the material,
maybe use it in teaching
others in the future.
So it'll stay on the platform
for anyone who wants to use it,
or anyone who wants to join
and use it in the future.
We think that
together, if we use
what we know about how work has
been structured in the past,
on what worked in the past,
what stopped working in more
recent years, why
the world of work
has to change to keep up
with changes in technology
and keep up with the people
who are doing the work,
we can make a difference.
So I want to thank you all
for the many hours of effort
that you put into this course.
I want to thank you for taking
an interest in improving
the future of work, and I
hope that together we'll
all make a difference.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]